with Shannon law  years of making games for Microsoft  rarely have I seen a community as  engaged and vibrant as the killer  instinct community thank you at e3 we  announced ki is coming to Windows 10  anything you own in ki you'll own on  both platforms and we're supporting  cross-platform play and on Windows 10  all of your existing controllers and  fightsticks will just work today I'm  excited to announce that killer instinct  season 3 is coming March 2016 - Xbox one  and Windows 10 I'm also excited to  announce the killer instinct feature  guest characters and that ki and rare  replay players can get a sneak peak of  rash from battletoads and he's coming  today  rats so that's what you got